-You know our next guest from
NBC's "The Office"
and "Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
as well as the films
"Pineapple Express"
and "This is the End."
He executive-produced
and stars in "Killing It,"
which is streaming now
on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-Oh, yeah, guess it was, like,
pouring rain
till like one minute ago.
The weather is crazy.
I don't care what Marco says.
Climate change is real.
-I believe in climate change.
-Doesn't take two people to
answer the door, Marco.
-Were you just, uh,
hiding a bike in our bush?
-God, seriously?
Why are you so obsessed with me?
-I am not obsessed with you.
I live here. It's my bush.
-Now it seems like
you're obsessed with bushes.
-I am not obsessed with bushes.
-Yeah, you are, and it's weird,
because it's not even
your bush, bro.
-It's in front of my house.
-But you rent.
You're borrowing that bush.
-Well, at least I have a bush.
-You're a bush borrower.
-You live in an apartment.
Bush borrower.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Craig Robinson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you, buddy?
-I'm good. How you doing?
-I'm good. You got a backpack?
-Yeah, yeah.
It's my "Seth Meyers"
emotional-support
Teddy-bear knapsack.
-Wow! That's --
-Yeah.
-Well, I'm touched.
-Yeah, you always give
such great gifts and stuff,
so I never have
anywhere to put it,
except for the bag you give us.
-Oh, gotcha.
So, like, you mean the greenroom
gifts that we give.
-The greenroom --
Yeah, I got cookies in here.
-Okay, great.
-I got a card from Seth.
-Yeah, I wrote a card.
-Y'all want me to read it?
-Sure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I haven't opened it.
Can you see that? "Craig."
-Yeah, that's --
People are gonna see
I have weird handwriting.
-Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, alright, alright.
This wasn't planned, guys.
-If I'd known
you were doing this,
I would have
written something longer.
-Oh. Well, no, that's fine.
"Craig, so happy
you're here in person."
-That's right.
So, that's very lovely,
'cause the last time
we talked was on Zoom.
-We were on Zoom.
-Yeah.
And now here we are in person.
-It was during last year.
-During last year.
And now, in that time, you have
shot a new a new comedy.
-Or the year before last.
-Was it the year before last?
-Wow!
-It's been a long time.
-Yeah, it has been a long time.
-So, congratulations.
This show is great.
It's "Killing It."
It's some guys that you met on
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
a show you were great in,
as well.
-Dan Goor and Luke Del Tredici.
-Lovely gentlemen.
-And this is a very, very
different kind of show.
I mean, these guys --
Obviously, they were involved in
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
but, tonally, this is different.
-It's me hunting snakes.
-Yeah.
So it's a little weird.
I met with Dan and Luke,
and they came with these ideas.
And it was like three ideas,
but at the end,
this one just stood out.
And it's real.
It's like people
actually are commissioned
by the government to hunt snakes
because, I guess,
back in the day, drug dealers
and whoever bought snakes
as pets, let them loose,
try to be like Scarface,
you know,
and they sent them out,
and now Florida
is overrun with snakes.
-Too many snakes, yeah.
The wrong kind of snakes.
-'Cause nothing eats the snakes,
but they eat everything.
-And now, we're you --
Did you have to get over
a fear of snakes?
Did you have that before
you did this show?
-I had a fear of snakes
till about 2015,
when I went to Australia with
my band, The Nasty Delicious.
-The Nasty Delicious.
-And we went to
an animal sanctuary,
and it was so amazing, Seth.
We met a cockatoo.
We sang till he started dancing.
His hair came up, a little Afro.
We met a koala bear,
and I held it.
It was the second-best hug
in my life.
The first was my mother.
-That's very nice.
That's very sweet.
-The second was this koala bear.
It felt like holding
a strong baby.
And then we met the snakes,
and I was gonna, you know,
pretend like
I was taking a picture,
but too scared to touch a snake.
But then I ended up touching it,
and it was,
like, amazing-feeling.
And they put
the snake around my neck,
and I was like, "Wow.
The snake means me no harm.
I've been misled by the Bible
and 'Indiana Jones.'"
-Have you ever had to
kill pests in real life?
-I had an ant problem
when I moved into my house.
Yeah, I didn't know ants
were so many and so organized.
-Yeah, they are.
-Yeah.
-People don't talk about
the organization of ants.
-They don't, they don't.
And they'll disappear
in a second,
'cause they know when you're
coming to kill them.
It's weird.
-They know
'cause they have a lookout.
They have a lookout ant --
very famous.
-Whoo!
-Okay, great.
-I get a little -- Yeah.
-You could have put that
in the backpack.
-Yeah, it was,
but then I was like,
"Let's put it
where I can get it."
-So, you learned --
we saw from that clip,
you learned some ASL for this.
-Yes.
-Did you have any base coat
before you started
doing this show?
-You know,
when I got my master's degree,
we learned to sign
the alphabet and numbers.
-Uh-huh.
-And so I had that base.
But then this was like
learning actual,
you know, words or phrases.
Shout-out to Rick,
my ASL teacher, who --
I thought it was
gonna be a long process,
'cause the first day,
I kind of fell asleep
when he was trying to show me.
But then, after that, I started
to get a rhythm with it,
and then I learned for
the scenes.
I haven't quite learned ASL yet,
but I learned for the scenes.
-That's great.
I want to ask about this,
'cause you have
an animated film coming out
called "The Bad Guys."
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm very excited about it.
Now, I got a 6-year-old
and a 4-year-old
Do you think they will enjoy
"The Bad Guys"?
And which bad guy are you here?
-I am Mr. Shark.
-Okay, great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
It's being hailed
as Tarantino for kids.
-Okay, that's good.
-So, yeah, check that out.
-I've been looking for that.
I've been looking for that.
But was it fun to do?
-It was absolutely a blast.
I did a lot of prep for it.
I infiltrated a family of sharks
for about a month and a half.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-The suit cost $12 million,
'cause you got to breathe
underwater, but it was worth it.
-Yeah.
-It was worth it.
But, no, it was a blast.
DreamWorks actually
pitched the show to me.
I went and sat
in their theater room,
and they were
showing me the cast
and what the shark
was gonna look like
and, you know, some of
the lines from the dialogue.
And I was like, "Hey,
you had me at 'DreamWorks.'"
-That's great.
-Yeah, it was dope.
-You're like, "Why are you
doing this pitch?
I would have said 'yes'
to anything."
-Could have
done this on the phone.
-You mentioned your band,
The Nasty Delicious.
You going back on tour
any one of these days?
-You know what?
May 4 at The Troubadour.
-Really?!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you excited?
How long has it been?
-It's been since New Year's
of -- What year is this?
-This is '22.
-Of 2020.
-Wow! So it's been a long time.
-So New Year's of 2020.
-Alright.
-So we coming together
like tigers in a cage.
-Alright. That's great.
I wish I could be there.
I can't wait for everybody
who gets to be there.
Thank you so much
for being here, Craig.
It's always such a pleasure.
-My man!
-My man. Craig Robinson!
All 10 episodes of "Killing It"
are streaming now on Peacock,
and "The Bad Guys"
opens in theaters April 22nd.
He's the shark.